uh
good morning everyone and welcome to mid
suffolk uh district council's
development planning referrals committee
meeting
um first of all can i just remind you of
some of the domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you're not speaking
please do not do not interrupt other
speakers and members are reminded not to
use
messaging or chat functions or emojis
during the meeting
unless it is to report a pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest
or to notify myself that you wish to
make a proposal
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open i.e teams chat and that if you are
contacted by a third party during an
application that's being presented
or debated you should please bring this
to the attention of our legal advisor
can i remind you that if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave the meeting
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair of the
meeting
please await your turn you will not be
using the hands up function except for
declarations of interests or site visit
requests or declarations of lobbying
and questions of clarity we will be
using electronic voting for today's
meeting
if you do experience any poor connection
issues in the first instance can you try
turning your camera off
if this does not work please turn off
all incoming videos
the options to find these are under the
three dots at the bar at the top of the
screen
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live on the
internet
and will be capable of repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting is recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make any representations to this
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to consent to having been recorded
this meeting sorry by entering this
meeting
as a speaker you're also consenting to
being recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
so just want to quickly run through uh
some introductions of who we have
joining us today
uh first of all ian de prez our legal
advisor good morning ian
are you with us yeah good morning thank
you
robert carmichael who's our governance
officer good morning robert
uh joe hobbs who's the case officer and
philip isbell the chief planning officer
good morning to you both
and the ward members are uh councillor
tim pasmore and councillor john
whitehead
so without further ado i'm going to move
straight on to the agenda
gender item number one is apologies for
absence and substitutions
can i now ask the governance officer to
do a role call please
and confirm any subs any absences
because we can't substitute for this
meeting
present present
present present
present present
present present
present present
present present
thanks very much okay and i gender item
number two is to receive decorations of
the cuny or non-pecuniary
interest by members do we have any
no that's none okay can i just ask
everyone to go on mute because
there's a lot of background um hissing
there we go thank you okay uh
agenda item number three is decorations
of lobbying
uh are there any decorations that
members wish to declare
so please could you raise your hands
okay i take that as none received thank
you uh
agenda item number four is decorations
of personal site visits does anyone need
to declare any personal sites visit
counselor mansell
yep thank you anyone else thank you
chair
i i believe i declared that i had
visited the site when we discussed this
at the previous planning referrals
meeting i haven't made any further
visits but i don't know whether that
needs to be noted
okay thank you uh anyone else
nope okay thank you for that uh gender
item number five
is confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 27th of january
um the draft is to be cleaned of these
minutes so they're not yet
to be decided at today's meeting but
they will come forward to the next
meeting
okay gender item number six uh to
receive any notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition
scheme do we have any
okay next is to move on to the schedule
of the planning application
before us so it's dc1800861
land east of edie road in claydon and
now i'd like to invite the case officer
joe hobbs to introduce the application
to the committee
thank you joe over to you thank you
chair
there may be one moment while the
presentation loads up and can you see
that uh screen there chair
uh not yet okay just give it a second
the internet connection is slightly slow
sometimes
and perhaps uh just let me know when you
can see the slide
yes i can see it fantastic
right okay okay so thank you chair and
the application before
members this morning is an application
which was considered by
a referrals committee on the 27th of
january of this year
i will go through the presentation again
as not all members were present for the
previous application
and also the scheme has been amended so
i will give a thorough presentation this
morning
and members will see in their committee
bundle there are there's a committee
report presenting the changes to the
scheme
um and the original committee report is
appended um
in the committee bundle appendices um
i wanted to draw out the changes that
have been made to the proposal for
clarity so the community report is
slightly shorter but then for
um completeness we've completed the uh
conclusion just to draw in all the
different factors of the
application um so the conclusion is in
the
um short committee report is the offer
the entire scheme so hopefully that
gives members a flavor
of the recommendation now so
to the proposals the application um it's
an outline application
with only access being considered today
but there are some indicative plans
within the application to give members
an idea of how the development could
come
forward in proposals the proposals are
now for 67 dwellings
open space ecology enhancements and
infrastructure and the site is landing
seville road in claydon
so just go through can i can i just
check can you see the second slide now
that says history of application yes we
can
it's coming through checking it's
keeping up with what i can see so just
quickly run through the history of the
application
the application was originally
considered in 2018 and
the committee asked for it to be taken
to referrals committee
with a number of matters to be clarified
the applicant at that point amended the
scheme to make significant improvements
to the ecology biodiversity and
landscaping of the scheme i'll show you
in plan
shortly and undertook a cumulative
transport assessment
with the nearby proposed development on
norwich road by pigeon investment
management that members resolve to
approve at the last committee for 269
dwellings and
primary school site and other matters so
that cumulative transport assessment is
undertaken and further mitigation
measures secured and again i'll show you
those at the end of this presentation
so members considered this application
27th of january
and the resolution was managed to refuse
due to poor design and impact
construction
and um impact of construction
and future residential traffic on
residential immunity
so it's shortly uh summarized slightly
um the applicants have now amended the
scheme
to reduce from 73 dwellings to 67
dwellings and reducing the density from
22 to 20 dwellings per hectare
gross they've relocated
and increased the number of single-story
dwellings on site i'll show you those or
bungalows
i will show you those on the plan
shortly and they've increased the
rough grassland buffer area around the
site and given an indication of the
biodiversity net gain calculations which
uh
provisionally showed to be over 15 so
i'll just run through those um in a bit
too so just to go through the site
location
and its border location the a14 and
if switch one second was going to put
the um pointer on
so you can see what i'm pointing we go
and here we have the application site um
within clade and barham
and just to show the parish boundaries
shown in green so we have the north of
the application site in orange
is in barham and the south is in the
parish of clayton and whitton
and just the brown line there showing
the existing development boundary
uh adjacent to the site
so just to give some uh indication of
the roads around
the access the site is accessed by ealy
road which is just shown here
and we have barham church lane just to
the north side
and here we have hereford drive and
extra road they're featuring the
committee reports just pointing these
two out and we have thornhill road which
connects to ealey road
and byron lane and just to show the
public rights away we have
the bridal way which goes across the
north the site showing a yellow there
and a footpath which goes down outside
the site but along
the east side of the site
so just to try and show the um access to
the site just wanted to show
um this slide here the yellow dot shows
uh
vehicle movements to and from the site i
just wanted to kind of go through
based on the concerns raised at last
committee and the way that traffic could
uh
move through clayton to get to the main
main road and obviously go north or
south so
just to show the first route we've got
edinburgh gardens
york present and to the main road
um also um york president you can travel
to the north if you want to go into a
bar and village center
but also there is access via thornhill
road to the north and byron church lane
where vehicle traffic could go and also
with the resolution to grant consent on
the south
side to the north that plan was just
showing in there we have the spine road
which has been permitted
which connects to thornhill road so in
due course as this scheme comes forwards
obviously residents will also be able to
travel out through that improved road
to get to the village and different
locations so there are a number of
routes through
the village that the different traffic
could take and um i think
um as we've often said before when
traffic is kind of like water it will
find the root of least resistance
when it travels through an area um and
if there are delays it will try and find
the quickest route through so i think we
can discuss further with highway
authority
present the meeting if needed later in
discussion but wanted to draw out those
different
uh different routes through the village
so just to run through the constraints
uh just to make members aware this is a
tree with tree preservation order on the
north brand of the site there and some
other trees just outside the site shown
in dark green
and we've developed boundaries shown
earlier
uh this was a matter which was raised at
the previous committee meeting 2018 just
showing the location of bar and quarry
quite far from the site the site is an
emerging safeguarding area and there's
an appropriate condition just to make
sure that we quantify any
minerals that are found on site to
address the
requirements of suffolk county council's
minerals and waste
so here we have the amended sketch
layout um
just to show the previous the current
proposals this was the original
proposals 2018.
i'll scoot through these the red areas
show areas of key change where the
scheme has been amended
just to pull back from the key landscape
features across the site the hedge
and the ecology mitigation areas and
that protected tree
and so the previous proposals shown to
members
in january were these and then if we
just go through to
the next area these show the um the
current proposals now what i will show
you in a moment is the parameter plan
which shows the changes a little bit
more clearly um but still we have the
main access into ealy road here
and development um uh um indicatively
shown i must add
um in these locations here there is a
parameter plan but this particular
layout is not set
um as it is only outlined it is only the
access that members are considering
today
but this has just been shown how the
drum accommodated taking account of all
the different
um restrictions and constraints on the
side
here the parameter plan this shows the
proposals a little bit more clearly and
how they've changed since
members last saw us in january so this
was the previous parameter plan
shown in january we've got the yellow
areas the ecological
mitigation buffer zones green open space
um sorry these are the plans these are
the plans as proposed now for my
apologies
these are the new plans just to make it
clear to members these are the new plans
because um
previously uh the single-story element
of the site was all located to the south
where now there are two areas of single
story dwellings proposed
one next to hereford drive and exeter
road and one next to winchester gardens
which was an area
that members had of concern
the
same one moment the um
the this this plan here apologies
members this plan here is the previous
one that you saw in january so here we
have the single story dwellings to the
south of the site
with that area shown in orange these
areas in red
are the areas that the applicants have
changed since she last saw the plans in
january so i'm just going to run through
these individually
but the first area is the single story
dwellings are now proposed in this
location as well
next to winchester gardens rather than
previously two story dwellings
we have increase in the ecology
mitigation buffer zone
just in this red area here and this red
area here
and this red area here
and so just to run through the proposals
one by one the
number of dwellings is reduced to 67
dwellings the density is reduced to 20
dwellings per hectare gross
and that's 30 dwellings by hector net as
you'll see in the committee report
single story development has been
relocated
there has been an increase in the number
of bungalows on the scheme from the
previous one
there were eight presented before and
now there's 10 so that's 15
of the total so that's a positive
benefit positive change since january
uh those in buffer areas have been
increased to try and create a bit more
space i'll show you those shortly
and an indicative a report has been
submitted showing it
looks most likely possible that we can
secure biodiversity that gain 15
on the site and we haven't thoroughly
tested this report it's just a piece of
information the application
applicants have submitted but it seems
entirely feasible with the amount of
ecological benefits and
mitigation ranges that this scheme does
secure and that's quite a positive
figure as our emerging joint local plan
seeks schemes uh to secure 10
biodiversity net gain
as does the emerging environment build
so that does show that the scheme will
achieve
a good gain for biodiversity and
certainly the proposals the parameter
plan does indicate that will be possible
uh also the visitor parking has
increased on sites just to create um
some more space for visitors where
possible
so just to transition the plans through
from the um previous this is the
previous and then
before your eyes it's just going to
change slightly to the proposed
it's very difficult to see the exact
changes um when you see that
transition but the buffer areas have
increased
in those red areas that i showed you
before and pushed the development up
slightly north as well as to create a
little bit more space for nature but the
key changes obviously are the reduction
in numbers
and the single story elements being in
two locations which could be secured
through planning condition to make sure
that the parameter plan is
adhered to and that they say single
story dwellings in perpetuity through
removal of permitted development rights
for upward extensions
so just to look at the plans i won't go
through these in too much detail this is
just the indicative site layout just a
little a bit more close-up detail just
to show
how the site could come forwards and the
applicants have shown that there could
be an access road provided through
site to the north i will come onto that
shortly in the emerging joint local plan
i'm just showing the potential
locate layouts to the south of the site
and then here's the parameter plan just
a little bit more close-up detail
okay and some cross-sections which the
applicants provided just showing how the
site could uh look and uh just uh
particularly with that section bb
and looking south you see the single
story elements um and then
the slight rays and land as we go
through
and just remembers information the
details have proposed access way into
the site as well we can look at that
more detail if needed
just to run through a video this is
turning
from um church lane
into thornhill road traveling down to
the site
ely road access
and here we can just see the sights in
the distance
and the access just in front of us there
and this video is of the opposite
direction so we've got the site entrance
behind us
and here we are just going along
thornhill road towards edinburgh gardens
which is one of the routes i showed you
earlier with those yellow dots
and just turning into edinburgh gardens
and the video just ends at the bottom of
edmond gardens when we
meet york president
there we go and just to run through some
photos of the site now this is just
looking
around the northern part of the site
with the access point behind us
just see the incline of the site there
as you move to the
east boundary of the site those mature
trees in the background
and then here's the southern part of the
site you can see hereford way
um extra road here for drive in the
background
that gives you indication of the uh the
rays and the land levels as well as you
look across the site
just look through some photos i've got
the photo location in the bottom right
hand corner of the slide
and just showing the access there into
from ely road
and there's winchester gardens just
along the north
west boundary of the site
here we have the public right of way
that comes through the site trees
on the edge there and this is just
looking across from the
northern point part of the site just
have more recent photo
um just to obviously some of the photos
are slightly older um
the site is in currently agricultural
use it's just taken to the public right
away
i'm just showing that relationship there
with winchester gardens
and a site a photo just looking across
the south the site
and here for drive and just a footpath
and that runs outside of the site
boundaries just to the
east there and this blue point is just
taken from the
application site the pigeon investment
management application site
you can see where the red dot is now
that is the application site this is the
land the north which there are no
proposals on that present
so now i'm going to run through the key
issues the key benefits
and just uh draw um the
matters out slightly into the uh that
have been drawn through the committee
report
the key harms in uh planning terms we
have conflicts with the current
development plan we're outside the
built-up area boundary we have tension
with those key policies called strategy
one and two
and um h7 of the local plan and we have
some landscaping impacts i'll show you
those um shortly in another plan
and we do have loss of greater
agricultural land although it's not
known whether it's 3a best most
versatile um
or 3b testing hasn't been done but it is
grade three on cultural land
and the key benefits the scheme of 67
dwellings
35 affordable which should be 23 units
as
the site is in a good sustainable
location uh well connected to
an existing uh core village that
that has services uh primary schools
and such like and a good sustainable
transport connection routes
the scheme proposed has a good ecology
mitigation enhancement measures and that
biodiversity net gain
looks to be a good a good figures
they're showing addictively from the
information submitted
and the public rights of way
improvements are secured to resurface
and improve the public rights way around
the site
and a number of hiring improvements in
clayton which i will run through just
in separate slides shortly just to show
some of the
context of the local services the
village we have the primary school
and we have uh clayton high school just
shown here and we have some shops in the
village core
um just where i'm hovering here at
present
and also we are in general context of
the district in a good location with
their sustainable transport connections
and the ability to cycle into ipswich
and to other areas of employment so
in the general context of our district
this is a good sustainable location
and accessible to those different
services and employment areas that
people need to get to
on the um emerging joint like your plan
obviously this has
limited weight at present but just to
draw out the fact that the application
site outlined in red
is within an emerging allocation in the
local plan
but it doesn't take up the whole of the
emerging allocation site which is
something that
we have discussed at the last committee
the whole of the proposed allocation
there is shown in blue
and so the application site is only
across part of that
i will just go through the surrounding
uh consents because it's something which
we didn't cover in the previous uh
meeting
this is land to the south of the
application site so the application site
is just
up here and consent has been granted for
nine bungalows on this land to the south
so just to show it on
on the context of the wider map there
here we have the proposed development
members of considering today that has
just appeared
and there we have just the south the um
the
permitted nine dwellings and that is the
wider site allocation
and i know this was a matter that
members did have concerns on the
previous application that we have an
emerging allocation for 74 dwellings
across this wider area here
and clearly here we have a pros of 67
dwellings
and nine dwellings permitted and with
the potential for further dwellings
coming forward
on this land to the north although we
have no applications
um indicating that at present i think
at this point um my advice to members is
that
we need to make a decision in terms of
the current development plan
the uh joint local plan it's a it has
limited weight and the phrase we often
like to use
is a direction of travellers to where we
will accommodate our
housing requirements in the most
sustainable locations um but at present
the allocations they haven't been tested
at examination so we can't give them
um more weight and that's the process
that that needs to go through
and um for the purpose of this planning
application um we
we can't um we can't uh get into the
kind of the details of the allocation
because that's a matter for the
examination of the
um the plan and the only thing that we
can do today and what members are
advising you is we have to make a
decision against the current development
plan
um and what that requires of us to
consider
whether this is a good form of
development whether it meets the
development plan or whether there are
other material considerations that
compel us to recommend approval and i
will draw on that conclusion when i get
to the end of the presentation
but hopefully that gives members of that
information as to what's happening on
the
wider emerging allocation
so just to show the public right-of-way
improvements these are the
footpaths that will be improved by the
financial contribution secured outlined
to members in the
committee report and there are a number
of ecological mitigation measures which
the applicants have
identified which have helped us to
really see how that will be beneficial
compared to the existing agricultural
use of the scheme how the there would be
space for nature and how there'd be
enhancements to really improve
that kind of biodiversity and
the kind of quality of the environment
for the
existing protected and priority species
in the area
the landscape impact that i mentioned
earlier there's a
major moderate landscape palm along the
public footpath
um here and for the residents of uh
surrounding the site just because
obviously at present there is an open
field and it would lead to a built form
obviously blocking those views limiting
those views but there have been
proposals to show
that that is limited in so far as
possible along the public footpath by
really pulling development away to kind
of give people a bit more of a sense of
space than they would have if there were
offenses certainly along that site and
that's something that we can secure
through the parameter plan and also now
we have obviously single-story dwellings
in this location uh which also reduced
that impact
to a degree from the president's and
their amenity winchester gardens
now just to show although there is that
major moderate landscape harm it really
is quite
uh limited within the wider landscape
we're not talking about long-range views
here it's quite a limited extent within
the
wider landscape that that harm occurs
the cumulative high impact assessment
was undertaken with the scheme for 269
dwellings to the north
and just to run through the improvements
that identified that were identified as
needed
are for pedestrians and cyclists at tiki
junctions in claydon
so we've got norwich road station road
there and norwich road church road
clayton junction so here we have the
church lane clayton junction
the crown public house some of you may
know and the existing zebra crossing
and just to show that there are
improvements to pedestrians
to improve their kind of safety for
crossing
this road here and a new footwear
widened
and the tree which will be retained just
the canopy raised slightly just to
ensure there's a visibility display
and just to improve those facilities for
pedestrians and cyclists
on the basis that there will be some
some increased traffic from this scheme
but obviously
this scheme has a more marginal increase
in traffic compared to the
cumulative accumulative map with both
applications
and here we have the station road and
orange road junction
in the centre of claydom and here we
have again
some improvements for off carriageway
and cycle
junctions and pedestrian crossing points
just to help
improve those facilities for pedestrians
and cyclists
but as members will note from the report
the higher authority and officers are
content that the proposals will uh not
lead to an adverse impact on the
severe adverse impact on the highway
network and will lead to no loss of
highway safety
for pedestrians cyclists and any other
road users
and one final uh uh improvement which is
secured through the highway mitigation
measures through the section 106 is this
relocation of 31 hour speed limit that
is more so in relation to the scheme to
the north but just to point out that
this scheme obviously is contributing to
all of those highway improvements
so i just wanted to go through the
previous resolution to refuse
with members just to try and draw out
what's in the
more recent committee report like i said
earlier we do need to consider the
current proposals against the current
development plan
which includes call strategy policy 9
which looks to have
30 dwellings per hectare on development
sites to try and make best use of land
but whilst considering what's
appropriate and thinking about the
context the character of the surrounding
area
also the national planning policy
framework you'll see in table papers and
just to draw members attentions to those
two paragraphs in the nppf
um 117 122 that look
to advise authorities to make the best
use of
land when developing whilst also having
considerations for other matters such as
you know appropriate design character
what is the surrounding and density of
development what would be suitable
but there are those two um paragraphs
officers do have in mind when they think
of how
development should come forward on this
land and we do need to make sure that
we make the best use of land whilst
balancing out all the other
considerations such as
design and amenity as i mentioned the
emerging joint local plan
has limited weight at present it does
give us that direction of travel and it
shows us that this site
is a site which has been identified to
accommodate some of our housing
requirements and it is considered to be
um obviously um a sustainable location
for to help us meet that growth target
but the policies themselves the precise
wording obviously aren't tested as yet
the examination so that's why we can't
give them anything more than limited
weight at present
and then finally um in the committee
reports our members will note uh the
um the appraised reason for refusal and
loss of immunity for construction
traffic
um this is something officers have
considered in detail since the last
committee meeting
um and we have had in mind the appeal um
that the uh
um council had in i at tufts road 126
dwellings
this was a reason for refusal concern
over the impact
of additional traffic accessing the site
via two access points
because of loss of immunity from that
additional traffic and as members will
see
in the committee report the
inspector did not consider that that was
a sufficient reason to refuse the
development because it is hard to
demonstrate that there would be a
significant and demonstrable harm
in terms of loss of immunity from those
residents that doesn't mean that those
residents won't notice there'll be
additional traffic
the area of character would change with
this proposed development here in
claydon
and from the additional vehicle
movements and to and from the site
but the test uh for um if we're
considering refusing the planning
application is
obviously is this demonstrable harm and
that would be an adverse impact and
immunity
and we don't con reviewing um how the uh
decision the reason for refusal and i um
played out appeal we don't feel that
there is sufficient um
evidence or level of harm in this
instance from these proposed
car movements to substantiate a reason
for refusal on that basis for immunity
here
so officer's advice is that bearing in
mind we have had a reduction in the
number of dwellings and the applicant
has responded positively to the previous
committee resolution
and just bearing in mind the other kind
of appeal experiences that we have on
this particular matter
we don't feel that it would be a strong
reason for refusal and officers
do advise against pursuing that loss of
immunity a reason for refusal
so just to draw together in summary the
whole scheme we obviously have the harms
shown here
about the development plan being outside
development boundaries although those
policies do have some reduced weight as
outlined in the committee report
we do have landscape harm and some loss
of agricultural land but then on the
positive side we do have the new
dwellings and the policy uh required
affordable housing being secured through
a section 106 agreement where a
sustainable location
in the grand scheme of our district is
accessible there are access to
sustainable transport links the
potential to cycle into key
employment locations as well as access
to services
in the village and schools we have a
good scheme for ecology mitigation space
has
been made for nature and there would be
an improvement for protected and
priority species
on the existing use of the land whilst
noting that obviously
development will happen there are
positive gains that can be secured
through this development happening
and there are a number of improvements
give the public rights of way
and the junction improvements in clayton
that we went through
the recommendation is for approval are
set out in the committee report
subject to the section 106 agreement
degree those matters and
their planning conditions and officer's
advice to members is that the proposals
they obviously are some conflicts of
development plan but the material
considerations
of the mppf um lead to officers they're
recommending that the scheme should be
approved
because we feel this is a good location
to help accommodate
our housing requirements and it meets
the requirements of our development plan
for the majority of the material
considerations
so thank you chair i'll pass back to you
thanks very much okay so we'll take uh
questions um what i suggest is because
we've only got sam
here uh on highways for um
25 minutes could i ask if you have a
highways question you put your hand up
first
if you don't you put your hand down and
then when we've dealt with the highway
questions
we'll then come back to other areas so
councillor guthrie
sorry i can't i can't get my hand down
quick enough i'm not always at the
moment oh
okay thank you councillor stringer
thank you chair uh yes i wanted to uh
thank you for the presentation uh i was
slightly
bemused by the construction traffic
statement
you shoo me a hall route and i counted
how many times
an hgv would have to mount the curb and
i got up to six
before you'd got to the site so
that that doesn't affect anyone's
meaning to your safety the fact you will
have
i mean i've looked at the figures to
build 67 houses
that's probably a thousand hgv movements
uh so that that we've got as a condition
that we agree the whole roots plural
i can't see one hall root into this let
alone
plural so if someone could advise me
what the whole
roots are that we're going to condition
uh as part of that that construction
method statement thank you
thank you council stringer okay thank
you chair um
yes the um i'm just trying to get to a
wider plan of the area we'll get to it
so counselor guthrie just so you know
your camera's on at the moment
sorry
um yes the um the hall routes would be
um
would be conditioned it would be
something we've discussed with the
highway authority
um when we um come to um agree
conditions and i'm
perhaps i'll ask sanders to come in to
talk about the um the process that we'll
go through to
to agree those um but um the
construction traffic obviously it is for
a relatively um short period of time
and we need to make sure that it's safe
obviously and that the highway can
accommodate those vehicles
um and that is something that the higher
authority have considered for the course
of this application
and it's not considered that that would
be a reason that we could refuse the
um the development it is possible for
construction vehicles to access the site
appreciate that there are um some um
you know there is evidence of parking on
the road you would have seen from the
videos
um but there are um there are routes
that the construction traffic can use to
get through into the site and then
access to the a14
um and that's something which the higher
authority feel that can be appropriate
conditions without that loss of
highway safety um sam was there anything
else you wanted to come in on
just on the concerns that there would be
a loss of highway safety from
construction traffic routes
yes thank you joe um the we would make
sure that
we have requested a construction
management plan has been included
and conditioned for for this site we
would work
with the developer to try and find the
best route
so as existing residents have the least
amount of disruption
also if there are any concerns with
regard to
areas where there will be any curb
mounting etc then we can
look at this with the developer to make
sure that
the if there's say for instance cars
parking or on a route
we can temporarily ask for uh waiting
restrictions
to make sure that the route is clear for
hdvs the route that's on thornhill road
and
also on ely drive they are 5.5 meters
so two hdb killers can pass
not fast they are slow but
the we will be talking again to the
developer to make sure that any
deliveries are
programmed to try and reduce the amount
of hgvs passing each other on those
roads
because as you say we don't we want we
want to make sure the pedestrian
and the existing residents um safety is
paramount
okay did you guys come back yes i did
there was no mention of residential
amenity
in that i mean
frankly i was expecting to see the hall
route coming in
on the other allocation uh and none none
of this existing estate
uh i cannot believe you could pass two
45-foot trailers on on that estate
safely
uh let alone a 45-foot trailer and a car
i i just quite like to see the drawing
before i ascend to this
well as um as we've said we've asked for
this to be conditioned
we would make sure that um the whole
route is
where the least amount of
um effect on existing residents so at
the moment
myself and joe have discussed it whether
or not it is on thornhill
and then coming down church lane and
coming onto norwich road
that is the the route that where there
is
less effect on existing residents
the but this again will be decided
when we have the discharge conditions
where the
developer will put forward their
proposal
i can't i won't tell them where to do it
where they're going to have their roots
i will look at the roots that they
propose
and then i'll recommend if this is an
adequate route or not
okay so let me just get this right
because this is absolutely critical
we've had this before so if it came back
that there was no safe
route on the existing road network what
happens
well there will be a safe route because
you've got to think about the amount of
people that have
any any vehicles coming into there any
removal vehicles you have bin lorries
twice a week or once a week twice for
for another week so
we would ensure that the the traffic
that the road is suitable for the
traffic that's coming onto it
okay and just to clarify what is the
short period of time that this will be
guaranteed to be happening in
well um it depends on the developer on
how quickly they build their homes
so for on on your past experience for 60
homes it can be a year can be two years
but on for 60 homes it's ordinarily
about a year
but that could be a question that you
asked the developer
thank you okay i'm going to move on to
counselor mayor
thanks chair um sam one for you if i may
um in your uh email of the 2nd of march
you state that edie rose
um this type of road will normally serve
100 dwellings
you then go on and add up the dwellings
including the new development and that
comes to 111
and and you then say that this is
accessible as shown in the design guide
can you can you talk me through about
you know what the design guide
says about the the limits um of number
of dwellings on the road is is there a
um the obviously the guidance is a 100
can this be
exceeded by a set percentage or what's
the rationale
saying that the 111 is acceptable
thank you yes thank you councillor
i can confirm that is a guide suffolk
design guide
that we have uh for any development
within suffolk
for a minor access road it actually says
residential roads with footways provide
direct access to dwellings
normally serve more than a hundred
dwellings so
we use a hundred as our base mark so um
that's where we have it it's normally
serve
more than a hundred dwellings when it's
shared access road is a
25 to 50 dwellings and a major access
road
is up to 150 to and can be up to 300
so it is it depends on the layer of
what's in front of us and for this site
100 a minor access road is suitable for
the number of dwellings that's being
proposed
yeah but why
this is a it's a guide 100 is a guide
and
you're deeming that that we cannot go
over that and that's acceptable
my question is what are the what is the
what are the reasons that you're using
to say that in this particular case
we can ignore the design guide and have
more than 100 dwellings
okay well on major access road major
access road is for a residential road
which would normally not serve more than
300 dwellings a major access road and a
minor access road actually
for this area is exactly the same
dimensions 5.5 carriageway and 1.8 wide
foot ways on both sides
the main difference between a major and
a minor access road is
is the um the visibility for
divisibility and the number of
staggered junctions spacing between
junctions that's where the major change
comes it's the layout rather than the
number
so i could say that this is a major
access road but i know it's not at the
moment because
of the number of dwellings that are on
there
okay thanks thank you understand
uh thank you one of my questions is is
about public rights of way which
i think might be related to highways um
am i allowed to ask that one now as well
or not
absolutely my first question is on the
indicative layout plan
um on the access road there looks like
two
it looks like it sort of widens just as
it gets into the site are they parking
places
or are they passing places uh that is
something to do with highways i presume
uh should i do the other questions as
well
or do you want to take them one at a
time let's just take the highways ones
first
well the other one is about public
rights of way okay we'll ask the
question
um uh the the the in the presentation we
we heard about improvements the public
right of way network
um and is there any um
thought to improve the slade
to be a bridal way or at least suitable
for cycles
and also the link to the slade from the
southern portion of the site there
appeared to be two
path links to the slade from that
bottom section would it be possible to
also have pedestrian access from the
public open space just to the north of
that
okay um thank you um just uh on the take
the questions in turn the um
bays here they would be um parking a
vista bays they they're not needed uh
they're not passing bays the road is
wide enough for vehicles to pass each
other in the access point here um
as for um the improvements to the bride
away i will just have to refer to
someone
whether it could become a bridal weight
as a cycle route certainly we're looking
upgrading the surfacing of um
of that route to cope with the
additional residents who would be
using it to walk along
the an additional uh connection from the
open space here the only um
concern about that is that it's quite a
mature um band of uh
vegetation woodland here at present so
that would lead to the loss of kind of
some quite um kind of valuable um
habitat um which obviously forms part of
the kind of the biodiversity net gains
that surrounding area where i think that
there certainly are kind of
existing gaps here where it makes it
well used this is the um
quite a well used path at the moment a
formal path into the site and so there
would be no loss of kind of vegetation
from these connections so that's the
only concern i have about um
recommending a connection to the
footpath at that point um
i just come back on that because because
at the
where your blob is there the little path
there which goes into the corner of the
access road for those houses
um and and just to the north of that
there looks like a thin
piece of hedge with a few trees on it uh
could there not be a gap there
that isn't a major piece of uh woodland
um we could look into it obviously this
is only an indicative plan at present um
it's certainly something that we could
look into the reserve master stage um
this is
a quite a strong field boundary across
the site and from memory
um i can't think of there's any gaps in
there but it's something that we could
look into just to make sure that we're
not agreeing any access points that do
lead to a loss of hedging trees is that
okay
thank you so i'm going to come back
about the upgrading the slate to a
brighter way
hello yes um thank you councillor i can
confirm that the public rights away
have asked for uh the surfacing
improvements
for the some of the footways
and i'm just checking on is saying
widening byram broadway number nine i'm
just checking to see which one that is
they there may be a sum of monies that
have been agreed
with the previous application to improve
uh the slade as in the application the
neighboring one on byram church lane
um so i'm just going to check that for
you and i'll come back to you
thank you thanks okay um counselor
guthrie and councilman mellon and we've
got uh
i know council got said she didn't have
a highways matter councilman is yours a
highways question
yeah at least yeah yeah if you'd like to
go next then then i'll bring cancer
guthrie the first of the non-highway
questions
uh okay thank you a couple of questions
um
the um the junction um at the top of
thornhill road with uh church lane bar
and we just need to understand
is that a direct crossroads uh into the
new estate uh because we're talking
about that potentially becoming a sort
of
a typical route for for users to use and
i'd like to know how
wide church lane byram is as well
okay thank you councillor um
yes the um the proposals here um let's
get the proposals for the
there we go the other application site
um it is proposed that would this would
kind of form a crossroads apologies it's
my superimposing of that plan on to um
the um the map there might
make it look slightly staggered but
certainly um that is a
that is intended to be a kind of a
crossroads when that scheme uh comes
forwards
um as for the um the width of um barham
church lane
um at present um i don't have that um
figure before me i'm not sure if sam um
has the information i know that um uh
it is currently a bus route um the bus
does
travel through uh clayton um well it has
it hasn't
recently yes traveled down that route um
to the main
road and i don't have the figure of how
wide
byram church lane is itself and sam do
you know do you have that figure to hand
at all
oh thank you joe no i don't have that
figure at hand i'm just having a quick
look on google and there is a center
line down the road
and normally with the center line in it
indicates that the road is wider than
5.5 meters
but i don't have that information to
hand i'm afraid
but as uh joe said it is a bus route
okay and when it comes to sorry and when
it comes to the crossroads
uh we've got got to remember with the
development the proposed development
in byram the actual crossroads won't
necessarily be a crossroad the priority
will be going to the new road
and because the uh church lane
uh byram old church lane will be
a dead end there'll be only locals using
that
route in to get basically to their
residence
yeah thank you um do you have another
but it's a non-highways question
yeah well you might as well keep going
uh because we've had all the high-risk
questions then we'll bring cancer
guthrie in next
okay thank you chair um um i just want
to ask
um the officer um you've mentioned the
the tufts road appeal in i as being sort
of material
uh in terms of um you know comparative
with this case but looking at the
the detail in in the package the the
tufts and
toss road one had two accesses and this
one has only one
so can you just sort of explain to me
what the what the um the relevance is
yes yeah um let me just quickly go to um
a slide um just so we can talk around it
and this is the um truss road
application
site so yeah there are two access points
um on this
uh on these proposals and obviously we
do have to consider each scheme on its
merits but i think it was worth drawing
this appeal into this debate just
because i think there are some parallels
um and there are two um access points
through existing kind of residentials
that are currently cul-de-sac so similar
to
the situation um and the proposals here
were for 126 dwellings
and um it was considered that um that
wasn't sufficient enough to lead to that
loss for meeting obviously the proposals
before members today we're looking at
67 um dwellings so um we're kind of it's
whilst you can't compare um there's no
kind of there's not
a cap on the number of dwellings which
then leads to a loss of immunity
planning obviously isn't such an exact
science but i think it does give an
indication that the inspector in this
instance felt that um broadly
um um with two access points for 126
dwellings
there wouldn't be a loss of mean t so um
officers kind of drew comparisons from
the um impact of 76 dwellings from one
access point
um the the loss of immediately wouldn't
be sufficient to
justify that reason for a refusal which
is obviously the test that we have to
make
when determining this application
thank you
counselor guthrie thank you for being so
patient
me thank you very much indeed um
probably a silly question really but um
whilst this is an outline and we're um
looking at access at the moment only can
we secure the
single story dwellings adjacent to
winchester gardens i know you said you
could secure it in planning conditions
and on page 64 um it does say
item two approved plans submitted in
this form application but i just wonder
if we can secure that
in case this site gets sold on or
anything like that thank you
thank you councillor um yes yeah we
would have in the condition that the
area is shown outlined in orange or
whichever color you want to call this
they would be single story development
the applicant is happy to adhere to that
condition
um and the the reason for the condition
is
to protect the immunity of those
adjacent residents um and so we feel
that it is a stronger than sound
condition and if someone
were to try and appeal it we feel we
would have a good justification for
opposing that condition so
yeah certainly it would be in the
condition that these areas should be
single story developments only thank you
thanks so much castor warboys yeah
yes thank you it's a point of
clarification really
uh in the conditions
you've got um on page 65 you've got a
phrase
energy and renewal integration scheme to
be agreed
does that um
is that shorthand for the um
accepting the recommendations of peter
chisnell
uh in particular
uh requiring a future
applicant for detailed planning
applications as it would be
to indicate the retrofit measures
required and to include an estimate of
the retrofit costs for the properties to
be developed to achieve
net zero carbon
[Music]
that is our condition that we would have
on um yes it should be renewable
um not renewal uh renewable and
sustainability uh yet to draw into
all those considerations um we um
it's a standard condition that we do uh
recommend in all of our um
our housing schemes and the precise
wording we would
we would work to make sure we have a
condition which achieves the best
possible
sustainability and renewable energy
measures possible that we can
secure um so i i don't have the precise
wording of the condition to hand it
present
but obviously we do need to work within
the bounds of what's acceptable which i
do set out in our committee report we're
obviously
looking to be more aspirational in the
emerging joint local plan but at present
we do need to
um work within the bounds of of what
i've set out in
i don't have the paragraph number to
hand but in the committee report before
members on
renewable energy and sustainability
thank you council matheson
thank you chair if i could first just
continue that clarification from
councillor roland
i think the the other words that we've
we've started to include
in that condition are concurrent with
reserved
matters um so so are we going to include
those magic words
in this condition also um yes certainly
yes yeah you'd want that information to
be designed with the reserve matters
stage to make sure that uh
the building orientation fundamentally
kind of
reflects the most sustainable um you
know kind of energy passive solar energy
gains such like so it's a matter that
you very much need to discuss at the
same time as the reserve matters it's
not something that you can disagree
afterwards so yes certainly concurrent
with reserve matters is what we'd be
looking at
good gradually establishing that yet my
actual question
was do we know whether the adjacent
development
twenty stroke zero zero six seven four
um
has commenced or is that still
effectively just
a site with permission
um my understanding is it's still a site
with permission permission was only
granted in november
um 2020 or december 2020 so talent of
last year um there are most likely
conditions that need to be discharged um
i'm i'm not aware
that they have discharging the
conditions but um certainly there were
no commencements on the site for the
most recent site photos that i saw
thank you okay thank you very much i
don't have any other questions sam can i
just thank you for joining us this
morning
and giving us an hour of your time thank
you very much okay i can actually answer
the
footpath question now yes the bride
awake for councilman
um the the request we have put in
is for an improvement to ride away
number nine which actually goes through
the site
that connects up to um the not the drift
um the the main route on the
east side of the site and also
improvements to footpath 13 and 14.
the uh the actual bride away itself
as i said is improvements to that to
meet
up with church lane that's what the
public rights away team has asked for
like could i just come back then yes
please so that
bridal way that i think sam is just
referred to
is the one that that skirts the northern
side of the that yellow one on that map
which then it is a bridal way all the
way
from the housing estate through to
church lane byron that is already a
broadway on my os map i know
um on the thing we've got here it's got
blue dots yeah
so all the way it's like a sweeping
curve you can get to church lane that is
a bridal way
so at the moment there are no plans to
make the southern part of the slade
which goes through to another road i
have no idea what the names of the roads
are
it goes all the way through to another
road that comes out the back of claydon
there's no plans to make that a bridle
way at the moment
yeah the public rights away haven't
asked for any improvements on that
at the moment thank you
okay thanks very much so we'll move on
um we don't have a representative of the
parish council or an objector
but we do have the agent richard martin
uh who now like
who now has three minutes to speak to
the committee so if you could turn your
camera on please mr martin
and your microphone on
okay thank you welcome chairman members
i'm richard martin a director at scott
properties and have been leading on this
project since work started in 2016.
since the committee meeting in january
we've been working with your officers to
address the concerns raised
the number of dwellings has been reduced
to 67. the housing mix is amended to now
include 10 bungalows or 15
of the homes these can be built to m42
or m43
accessibility standards as required
through reserve matters
on the matter of landscape impact the
number of dwellings backing on to
winchester gardens has been reduced from
15 to 10.
all build form has been pulled away from
the boundary to create a wider buffer
the plots which back directly onto
winchester gardens are now
all single story removing any potential
for overlooking
these measures are set out in the
parameters plan and can be secured
through conditions
in respective ecology the buffers to the
site's eastern boundary have been
widened
providing additional areas for habitat
creation a biodiversity net gain of 15.9
percent can be delivered through this
development
significantly in excess of the 10
requirements
in terms of highways impact there will
be a reduction in vehicle movements
arising from the reduced dwelling
numbers
two additional visitor parking bays are
also shown in excess of the policy
requirement
in order to reduce the likelihood of
on-street parking in the immediate
vicinity of the site
on the subject of density the revised
development for 67 dwellings
represents a gross density of 19.9
dwellings per hectare
the following gross densities can be
found in the surrounding area
19.6 dph on the consented site
immediately to the south
also part of proposed allocation la 03
24 along exeter road and hereford drive
28 along ealey road and winchester
gardens
and 31 proposed besides la 01 to the
north of clayton
we are grateful to this committee for
the detailed feedback provided in
january
which we recognize has resulted in a
more balanced and generally improved
development proposal
following the re-consultation this
application is again being brought to
members with no objections from the
technical consultaes
and with officer recommendation for
approval we believe this application
represents a positive development in a
sustainable location
that will provide benefits for the local
area and the district
we very much hope that you will endorse
the benefits of the proposal by granting
your approval today
thank you
thank you very much uh any questions i
have one that's not
real i'm not it's not massively
important or relevant but i'm just just
in our papers it says the applicant is m
scott properties and then it goes on say
the
it's an edmondsbury and ipswich diocese
so do i take it the church
owns the land and you're representing
them
the church of england ends the land
thank you chair um yes the site is in
two ownerships um divided
um by the by the hedge line which runs
through um the southern boundary so
i hold the southern third so it's
roughly a one-third is owned by the
church two thirds by a separate private
landlord
thank you um okay any questions at all
any
other questions no okay thank you very
much thank you
mr martin okay we'll now move on to the
ward members
we have councillor tim password
councillor john whitehead i know council
tim pasmore
has uh emailed to say that council
whitehead is speaking on behalf of them
both
so councillor whitehead over to you
oh thank you uh good morning members yes
councillor passmore can't be here today
but he's happy for me to speak on his
behalf
and equally as a clayton parish
councillor my fellow parish councillors
are equally content for me to speak on
their behalf
so seven weeks ago in a full day session
this committee first approved and
outlined
269 new dwellings in barham then after
careful consideration and debate
reminded to refuse this application 18
to below
861 for an additional 73 dwellings on
this ely road site
it was very clear to anyone viewing that
community meeting that you committee
members
had some real concerns about the sealy
road clade and development
the reasons why you are so minded to
refuse this application is set out on
page
14 of the new report and there's one
theme
running through that paragraph which can
be sent up in one word
traffic that word traffic appears five
times in that short paragraph
can i just say that both myself and
council pass tomorrow's ward members
along with the parish council and many
residents that i've spoken with
all wholeheartedly agree with the
conclusion that you came to
regarding the traffic impact in that
january meeting
but of course the 27th of january wasn't
the end of the matter it was only a
minded to refuse decision
with the committee instructing officers
to negotiate a lower density of
development
you were signaling that some lower
density development
could be acceptable to you as a
committee so i guess the big question in
my mind now and i suspect in the mind of
residents watching this virtual meeting
is whether you as a committee are as
totally
underwhelmed as we are with the
negotiated reduction of just six houses
the report on page 14 i quote says
the application subsequently been
amended with the proposed
dwellings reduced from 73 to 67
dwellings
representing a 10 reduction in the
number of dwellings proposed
now by any normal calculation a
reduction of six on seventy three as a
percentage is eight point two percent
which we rounded to eight percent not to
ten or
nine percent so let's first clearly
acknowledge this reality
the negotiations resulted simply in a
mere eight percent reduction
now i'm wondering what percentage
reduction you're anticipating obviously
there's no process here
where i can get individual answers from
you now but perhaps that will become
apparent during the debate
personally i would have been
disappointed with any outcome below 25
a drop of a quarter 25 could be
described as a real change
not just some half-hearted tinkering to
the number
25 reduction would have reduced its
application
to 55 dwellings would have started to
make some real
albeit still modest reductions in the
traffic impact
that you clearly identified back in
at january last meeting i described the
traffic situation on the roads within
the clayton garden estate
as this 1960s development between the
site and the village centre is called
in paragraph 6.12 the traffic
implications concentrate on again
i quote the development would lead to
delays at two key junctions in claydon
now as i try to explain the last meeting
the resident's main concern is not at
these junctions
we're actually quite polite lotting
clayton we're fairly happy to queue for
a few seconds more at a junction
our main traffic concern is the fact
there's been so much
on street parking most of these estate
roads regularly become
unpleasant obstacle courses and
edinburgh gardens in particular
can best be compared to a downhill
slalom ski slope
sleek course we weave our way from one
side of the road to another as we pass
parked cars squeezing into tight gaps to
graciously let through
oncoming traffic and unless you drive a
high suv
it's very difficult once you've nipped
into one of these small gaps between
parked cars
to know where the next small gap is so
when we set off on the wrong side of the
road
in search the next refuge we
occasionally find ourselves on the wrong
side for much longer to anticipate
causing irritation and road rage and
those who believe their right away has
been impeded
and of course things get even worse at
um
things get even worse at school drop off
time and collection time
in both edinburgh gardens and new york
crescent
social media is fully full of it even
stressing that you're crescent
we made a one-way street the social
media describes the chaos on the
gridlock
the stress and the anger the near misses
and the root gesticulations
so here i'm not just describing some
apocalyptic future
after this application has been approved
i'm talking about the current status quo
before we add the thousand plus hgv
construction movements
i've described an everyday normal day in
the clayton garden estate
so for my residents the number of new
houses that are tolerable
on this proposed development is actually
a big fat zero
dropping the number from 73 to 67 as i
said said earlier
it's just merely tinkering around the
edges so frankly it's an insult
remember i hope you share our anger in
my view
in the view of council of passmore in
the view of the parish council and i
believe the vast majority of local
residents
the reasons for refusing the 73
dwellings on this beautiful site
outside the village boundary which is so
clearly set out on page 14 of the papers
applies just as strongly to this
marginally reduced application
for 67 dwellings it's gone down by eight
percent
but what remains still a whopping 92
percent of the original
is still way way way too many members i
do hope you'll agree
thank you
thank you very much do you have any
questions for the ward member at all
uh yeah we've got a hand up from
councillor guthrie
thank you chair um i see the lovely
picture of poppies behind you but what's
actually on this um quality land what's
what's grown on it normally please
um so another farmer i just
see sort of green stuff occasionally but
i think i think to be honest i think
back for the last several years since
it's been proposed as a
uh as a site for housing by the by the
owners they haven't done much
farming as such on it which is why it
became such a beautiful
um boundary to the village as you see
the poppy field
um this was taken probably just just
under a year ago around
may time last year during lockdown when
it was an
uh you know a nice sort of outlet for
people just have a short walk
away from the village and uh yes
thanks beautiful whitehead i think i
just wanted to know
what the quality land was being used for
thank you
yeah thank you chair this
uh part of this site is in
allocation la double 003 in the joint
local plan
in the joint local plan that is for 75
homes has the parish council objected to
this
and if if you haven't what what
percentage
of this site is is it of la double o
three i
la double o three is saying we'll do 75
houses
i believe this site is only a portion of
la-3
um i'm just trying to work out how much
over the allocation number
in the joint local plan this density
represents
thank you chair if you do you have those
numbers if not we can bring
joe hobbs back and probably can help
i prefer to revert to the officer on
that okay
thank you chair um yeah the um emerging
allocation
um um identifies um 75 dwellings
um the two proposals um the
scheme that has been permitted um of
nine dwellings to south and 63 here
um at least a total of 76 dwellings um
with further
land obviously to the north still within
the allocation
um it's as i as i mentioned earlier to
members in the um presentation
we can't really get into a kind of an
examination of the
emerging uh site allocation through this
it hasn't been tested yet
at um at the examination um
and certainly um it's difficult to start
to plan this site to the north here
um if you can see on the screen now um
the uh the allocation this uh site to
the north here
um because this site does have some
constraints in landscape terms and
heritage terms we have barham hall here
um and it's difficult to say precisely
henry dwellings could come forward on
that side but it's
it's not really a matter that we can um
uh debate in this committee
um in terms of the numbers on the
allocation because we can only give
the joint local plan limited weight at
present it is difficult to say that
that is a reason that we should be
refusing this number of dwellings on
this site
we have to make an assessment against
the current development plan which is
the proposals on design immunity
density and our core strategy and
if it is proposed that the allocation
wants to achieve 12 dwellings per
hectare
across the whole allocation which is
what the um 75 proposed
across the um six um a m hectare site if
i
remember the six correctly but it's
definitely twelve dwellers per hectare
if that's what the allocation um
wishes to do so that is the matter that
we would place weight on once the
allocation becomes
um more um part of the development plan
and we can place weight in it but at
present because it hasn't been tested we
don't know whether an inspector
or whether the kind of um that will pass
um all the requirements of the
examination that that's why officers
have recommended that we have to look
towards the current development plan
i appreciate that um it's uh
it would be you'd rather kind of have
the clarity as to whether um what what
the allocation you know um that the
allocation decides this and that's what
we want to come forward on this site
but like i say we have to make the
recommendation now based on the current
development plan
um and that's what officers have done so
in their report okay thank you
uh council ebern you have a question
thank you very much chair and thank you
council whitehead for your
your representation um i just wanted to
ask i understand
um clayton doesn't have a neighborhood
plan has there been discussions
of having one and secondly um with
regards to this particular proposal
um has there been a you know open house
consultation
in the village thank you right uh well
in terms of neighborhood plan
the fact is that clade and barham and
really great blaken together
are a one big blob as such and any
neighborhood plan it was always seen
would sensibly need to involve clade and
barham and great blacknum
efforts were made about several years
ago to try and
get this off the ground and
unfortunately it did just grind to a
halt because first of all
barham didn't want to get involved and
uh well
there's a long story which you probably
don't want to hear but um
they uh despite some best endeavors of a
valiant few including myself we were
never able to
get a neighborhood plan to get an
attraction there
and sorry your second question was it
was just the the
extent of consultation of this
particular site thank you
um for a long time this site has almost
been eclipsed by the 269
uh uh you know adjacent or above barham
church lane
so it was always sort of so much of the
focus in the village was always on this
on the bigger site where there was a um
lots of consultation um village hall
meetings etc
and um
that was i think that one came forward
in 16 or 17
and then this one has come forward in
2018 and i say
really all the way can you decide
all the way along the line this
application has really been eclipsed by
the much bigger one
yeah i think so the consultation on this
site is was the question
yeah um it's sort of running together
um there has been yes
thank you thank you any other questions
for the ward member
no okay now um we traditionally uh i'm
we should always have a break
i always believe every 90 minutes and i
think it would be
it wouldn't be good to have sort of two
speakers because we're now into debate
about to go into the debate so rather
than have two speakers to then break i
think what we'll do is we'll take a
break now
and start again at 11 o'clock in 12
minutes time so everyone can just
quickly stretch their legs uh take a
comfort break and we'll
we'll start the debate and reaching a
conclusion
at eleven o'clock
thanks everyone and welcome back so
we'll now go we've had all the
information presented to us
by the our officers
and also from the heard from the
applicant or the agent and from the ward
member
so members over to you to discuss debate
and to reach a conclusion on this
application
who would like to go first
councilman
thanks chair my concern when we
discussed this last time
was access and that really hasn't gone
away
to have 67 dwellings and one entrance
seems to me ridiculous you know is it so
far-fetched for that entrance to be
blocked
and then an emergency vehicle can't get
through
no i don't think it is um
i do have some notes from um
a previous after the last one i went to
the design guide
and and there is a comment there that
cul-de-sac serving such number houses
over 50
must have a footpath that links with um
other road networks
well there is no secondary link relying
on
a link that might go through the north
of the site at some point in the future
well we're not discussing that we're
discussing this application
and this application access does not
have sufficient access
to keep those people safe so
i i'm mindful for refusal purely on that
thank you
that's the cast and then counselor
thank you very much mr chairman um
yeah so there has been changes to this
application since the last one i do
welcome
the single story on the back of the um
houses there because i thought the
overlooking was a very serious
problem with this the um i agree with
council
mayor um it does come down to um
the access um for me the um
i i totally agree with everything he
said um
just then the um the byram church lane
we
discussed the width of that um road
and the um that that's not a five and a
half
meter road i've done a quick google um
um earth look at that and i think
in it's about five meters i do
travel up and down that road quite
regularly and um you do ha
traffic does have to stop to let other
cars through
um that um that's a big issue because
that there's two there's two accesses to
this there's up barham
church lane and there's um edinburgh
gardens
edinburgh gardens completely agree with
councillor whitehead
it's um there's it's a slalom course
um through there the um cars have to
constantly give way
to other cars but um to
looking at the use of the land is quite
a um
big part of this for me um it is
agricultural land the um the picture
with the poppies
is a field of rape and a um
a treatment for those poppies hasn't
been put on that um
field so um that's that's where the
poppies have come from
that's kind of a um a failure of um
intensive farming but um
not really a failure for um the
environment and
and the wildlife on there but um it is
on google earth for wheat field
um but it comes down to the usefulness
of that land it's a two hectare field
and a one hectare field
um it's kind of land locked if from
the ownership of the field going on to
um
byron church lane is um with another
um landowner because um you can see
quite clearly that access that feels
taken through
barham church lane there is access
through um
the same access we're looking at for
this planning application
which um obviously would not be ideal
farm machinery traveling through um edie
road and um
and around that way um so
it for a two hectare and a one hectare
field it
it's a it's a very inefficient way of
producing
crops it's a lot of um a lot of carbon
for
your output and and it's quite near the
houses so
for me those fields aren't massively
useful but i don't
think that this really comes down to
that i think this
this comes down to is it is that access
suitable
for this development and i agree with
council the mayor and saying that i
i think there's serious problems with
that access
so um i'll listen to debate and um thank
you very much mr chairman
thank you i'm just going to bring in
phillip is bill who's just put his hand
up probably to comment on that point
uh thank you chairman yes um just just
so
uh members of uh i i i think and
uh take this to this forward as as the
right way can we start off
i mean council may have talked about
footpath connections and i'm quite clean
we're just clear what
the links are here now there's obviously
the
vehicular link into uh early road so we
we know that we've got the bridleway
runs across the top of the site doesn't
it
uh joe
and then there's uh sorry joe if you
could just highlight where the
bridleways which i think we talked about
surfacing improvement and then there's
the
there's another plan you've got actually
which has got these on i believe
and then there's the footpath
connections uh here as well
and this site does have connectivity
into the bridal way does it not
which in turn links into the rest of the
estate at
the point where you've got your cursor
there so
in very simple terms there are two
egress points into the estate
uh there at the very least uh in
addition presumably one will be able to
root through to the
uh uh brighter way across the top of the
site and connect onwards from there and
that looked from the photographs you had
up joe being fairly well used running
north
north west south east so i think members
do need to
give consideration to how those access
points root
and then joe could you get up the tufts
road plan that you had previously
relating to the eye appeal which is
obviously mentioned in in the papers
so for members benefit you will recall
this was
recommended for permission and was uh
overturned by planning committee
uh at the time uh that's an application
i believe for 126 dwellings
so arguably if one uh assumed that
traffic might split equally that would
be
of the order of a little over 60
dwelling
households households traffic heading
out through each
connection point so
we're dealing here with 67 dwellings and
in terms of the position officers take
and the advice we'd give to you as a
committee
the traffic heading out from that site
assuming that it might split equally and
that is an assumption
um would then feed into the adjacent
road networks
of the estates and go onwards and
was not found to be an issue that was
unacceptable to
uh the secretary of state's inspector
that's dealt with in paragraph 2.9 of
the committee report and indeed the
inspector acknowledged that
where you live in a residential
environment such as this you are to
expect
and and can reasonably expect
residential traffic associated with
the kind of change proposed so uh
to take the question of volume of
traffic going through this access
i think to deliver the allocation and
going back to the point about jlp it's a
long way off having any weight
that is material to this conversation
they would probably come forward a plan
which routed access into
uh this this road network
possibly from sandy lane byram also from
churchland byram
and uh would split traffic out of it
it might well have a volume of houses
coming off
all of that is speculation but for
comparison purposes
committee took a view on this
application
and there are comparable factors here
around the volume of traffic that might
be associated with
and the inspector did not accept that
argument
okay can i just bring in councillor
mayor because you did
raise the point in the beginning
councillor mayor
yeah my concern was predominantly
emergency vehicles access and the
secondary access
um mrs bell has pointed out there is
that secondary access available
which i have missed so my concerns have
been largely dealt with
so um yeah i'm going to sit and listen
to the rest of the debate but
i haven't made any recommendation thank
you thank you councilman okay
thank you very much for that uh next up
is councilman miller
uh thank you chair no i listened with
interest to what colleagues have said on
this and i too had serious concerns
about the access particularly again what
kind
of mayor said for emergency vehicles but
i think um mr isabel has sort of you
know clarified the point with regards to
this access and it's something we see on
lots of estates around the district um
so i'm in two minds on this one at the
moment but
you know i'll listen to what everybody
else has to say before i sort of make a
decision on this particular
application thank you chair
thank you councillor guthrie thank you
for that um could the officer put up
um slide 36 please
which shows us the key benefits while
she's doing that
i will say i appreciate the jlp
has little weight particularly with
numbers
so it can't be the panacea for us to
make a full decision here
but the problem is some members myself
included have been on the jlp
working group um and this site
is forward for approval
for development of some description at
some time
so we've got a conflict that what we've
got of knowledge of what
might happen but we've got to look at
what's here today
um i'd be interested to know about any
traffic management plan
for the other nine houses on the other
side
um i listened to um councillor field
that councillor
i've done that again haven't i sorry
john
um the the award member
i've listened to him carefully and i've
also listened to councillor casting
saying it's like a slalom
going down there which happens a lot on
such areas
but i i have been told when i've
objected to some planning applications
that
no one has the right to park on the
highway
which seems quite harsh but that is a
fact
i like the improvements that the
applicant has brought forward um
particularly the key benefits i'm
comfortable with the landscaping ecology
um sustainability and the affordable
homes
and as i questioned earlier regarding
the bungalows
i was pleased that the bungalows would
not have such an impact
on those properties and winchester
gardens
i too worry about
harm and it is very difficult when you
come to planning decisions
to demonstrate the harm and i think
we're all in the same boat that where i
live
pretty rurally um i have local
neighbours who have increased
traffic and it it will cause
a harm but to demonstrate it to go to
appeal
i think would be very hard and with with
the i1
we can quite clearly see that although
they put up a good fight on that one an
inspector
wouldn't use it uh for an appeal
so i too have concerns about the traffic
but with all the comments that are being
made and mr isbell
um i will sit and listen because i think
slide 36 probably gives us
a good benefit thank you
thank you uh counselor eben
thank you very much chair um when we
considered this earlier one of the
things that i'd raised particularly
was the landscape buffer
and while i appreciate the changes the
applicant has
has done to ensure we have a slightly
wider buffer they're still
um to me there needs to be a kind of
equivalent of a field edge buffer
between the the housings and the
and the woods area which through which
the slade
that path runs um so
i appreciate there's more being put in
but it it would have been
you know an incremental meter is you
know we we could do with
a lot more than that and i think
with regards to the access and the
traffic i mean
to put it bluntly the construction of
this site is going to be a nightmare for
residents
um and but that's the same situation
that's happening in villages all across
our district and you know it will be
highly irritating to um residents in
those surrounding
roads in there while this is being
constructed
um one of the potential things for the
future they might
want to consider is putting getting 20
mile an hour zones um throughout that
area
um and addressing the sort of park
off-road on-road parking and so on
elsewhere but that's not something we
can
add to this application or discuss today
so i'm kind of sitting on the fence
because the
you know i can see the applicant's major
changes the
increased amount of bungalows is is
really good and
they have improved the um ecology
buffers although for my mind not quite
enough
um so i will wait to see what the rest
of my colleagues say thank you very much
chair
thanks counselor matheson
thank you chair um the
the officer didn't really list the the
the loss of amenity
um as as a key harm or even as a harm i
think
um but clearly it is it is some harm
um county are not saying
that there is no harm they're saying
that
it's not bad enough to refuse which is
not
not not an attractive position to take
up in my view
unfortunately and um i think that the
as we've seen the this this is not the
allocation this is a part of the
allocation and i think i
have to unfortunately repeat myself from
last time that the
the allocation had three access points
for traffic
and this has one and and that is
that is a major problem to me um
given that it's tucked away behind an
existing estate i
i i was on the tufts road
committee that day and i i certainly
voted for refusal
i didn't think it was very good um
the appeal inspector didn't agree but it
doesn't really persuade me very much
that this is this is a better
than that um possibly it's a bit worse
than that
now it is clearly it's a sustainable
location clayton and barham
have got good sustainable links to
ipswich
and they've got there have quite good
services in the village as well
so i don't there's any argument this is
a relatively sustainable location from
that point of view
the point is um you know is it going to
be
satisfactorily developed as a good
development i think the officer did did
you know say that this for the committee
to decide
um that this is a good development well
i'm afraid i don't think it is a good
development
as before us at the moment and i did
establish in the questions
that the it remains open to the
the two land owners here
to talk to the landowner immediately to
the south
who has permission for nine which have
not yet been built
um to actually put together a better
scheme which would record
more not 100 percent but would accord
more
to the allocation which is limited way
as we know because it's in the joint
local plan not yet adopted
but nevertheless a better scheme could
be brought forward so
at the moment i i proposed um refusal
last time and i'm not
actually changing my mind about what i
think about it at the moment
okay thank you councilman
uh thank you uh i mean i i i
certainly agree with much of what has
been said before
um and i do actually find it quite
interesting
that we had a detailed analysis of the
um farming land from councillor castin
for this relatively small piece of land
which i think in the papers and in the
presentation
we're told it was grade three um when
rarely we
we mention it even when it's grade two
so i find that quite interesting that
that was
uh part of the debate um and i certainly
don't deny that
i think there will be an awful lot of
traffic generated from this
this is a development both in the
construction phase and once it's
finished
and there are an awful lot of tortuous
roads with lots of cars parked
for people to get in and out of it but
unfortunately
we are where we are and highways have
said it's acceptable and we've often
been
in this situation where we as people who
who live in the real world maybe um
understand that the residents
are going to find it very annoying that
they've got an awful lot more traffic
but if highways say it's okay um and
when we are comparing this with other
application and i
when when traffic movements through the
housing estate was not deemed to be
a reason for refusal i think if we do
refuse this i think we will be in in
quite dodgy
territory because because to all
extensive purposes
it's okay um i i agree um with
councillor ebern that
some concessions have been made but
maybe they're not quite enough
um and i think we are actually in quite
an unfortunate position
as as councillor matheson has said that
the
other um site just to the south of this
it's already got nine
houses permission and we also have the
vacant plot of land
to the north of this site which also
forms part of the allocation
in our joint local plan and now had all
three of these plots
come through together we could have had
more than one access point but
but we are where we are and i think
we've got to determine this
um and you know there have been some
concessions maybe they could have done a
bit more
they could have put a few more a few
fewer houses on
but you know i feel that there is some
way
there is some movement in the right
direction um that the
developer is willing to to make make
these concessions
um so again i'm afraid i'm i'm a bit
sitting on the fence i think it is going
to be difficult but i can't see
any grounds of refusal um and then one
thing i would like to mention is that if
we are minded to approve
i would like some sort of informative um
about
making that less than half a kilometer
of footpath along the slide between
where it's a bridal way and where it
becomes a byway
to be upgraded to be a bridal way
because otherwise it's a hole in the
public rights away network as i see it
so i'm not proposing anything but should
we be minded to
um approve this i'm i'm wondering
whether that could be an informative
thank you thank you councilman so uh uh
philip israel has put his hand up so i'm
going to bring
phil in before i go to
cancer just just picking up a point i
think counselor guthrie had raised it
there was a little bit of conversation
around it and just to
add some information to it in relation
to the adjacent site
so uh that development of nine
bungalows um as
we say that's got planning permission
there's no discharge conditions against
any of them at the moment condition 12 i
recall of that
is a construction management plan which
is yet obviously to be agreed so
so that was that was part and parce
biodiversity measures uh
associated with it so uh that decision
has taken in
some of those things
i'm conscious and i believe if you look
at the
local plan submission it doesn't
actually identify any access points for
the land so i think all of that is to
be resolved so i'm not completely sure
that access is
is in any way led by the jlp um
draft allocation but understanding that
there was that there is an offer of 15
biodiversity enhancement here and that
this is a matter which i think
as uh joe was saying exceeds what's
what's ex
what will be required within the jlp's
policy i do wonder we've currently got
conditions on that and i don't know if i
could bring joe in just a comment as to
whether or not that might
to give members some confidence in it
might more usefully be locked into the
section 106
uh obligation as a way of making sure
that that 15
is actually cheap because to to
benchmark that we doubtless take advice
from uh
sue houghton and play services but
perhaps jeremy with your permission i
might ask joe to comment on that
um yes thank you chair um yes and the
applicants have submitted a report
from their consultants demonstration
that 15.89 percent precise um
biodiversity net gain could be secured
and uh we haven't yet uh kind of gone
through the process we would do
um to discharge condition to um check
all that information out but the
applicants are certainly confident that
they can meet that level of fifteen
percent
biodiversity net gain and so it's
something which we could uh
place in the section 106 agreement um
with further discussion with the
applicants just to give it that
kind of certainty and security that that
enhancement would come forward
and hopefully that kind of gives members
that kind of comfort that um there
really would be
something kind of quite um good about
this site and that it does deliver over
and above
and where we are going with the joint
local plan and the environment bill when
it comes to biodiversity net gain so
that is something that we could do if
members were
minded to uh seek that and manage to
improve
thank you thank you for that um i've got
four more speakers and i'll give my
thoughts on it
uh councillor stringer thank you chair
uh this is one of those uh
oh wait a second that's better this is
one of those
cliffstick situations uh we
we're sort of damned if we do and damned
if we don't uh i just want to uh
first of all make a few comments about
highways in criticism and then
offer some support um it is always
annoying
when uh the real world is sketched out
in terms of highways terms because it
the the two never seem
to meet uh we know that we're not really
allowed to use a lot of
data in terms of the construction
because technically someone could build
these all with a with a wheelbarrow
they won't they'll be using an enormous
amount of
heavy goods vehicles to do it which is
why i was asking the questions early on
i would i would certainly expect if this
development were approved
that that it would only use one of those
entrances to introduce
a heavy goods vehicle into edinburgh
gardens uh
something 45 foot long track to unit
would be utter ridiculous
so i mean and i can't believe that we
can't we can't
stand up to that but of course the only
problem with this is
the bar that the highways team have to
work to
is set by government and that bar is so
incredibly high
it demonstrates that you have to you
have to almost prove
someone is highly likely to get
seriously injured before you can do
anything
and and frankly i think the government
if we want to see what we believe is
sustainable development
i think the government needs to lower
that bar somewhat uh
yeah because it is too high at the
moment
we are in a bit of a mexican standoff
here we see a lot of these
where you've got in a perfect world if
you were master planning this
you would master plan all three
landowners all at the same time
to use proper entrances and there'd be a
whole route in here
for the construction phase job done
you've then minimized the amount of
hassle to everyone
and and and the loss of residential
amenity there will be
loss of residential amenity either way
with this allocation
to those residents on that estate uh and
and that's very very saddened it's our
duty to see if we can minimize it as
much as we can
but we are also dealing where government
does give us a fig relief where they
allow us
if we want to master plan things to
invoke something called a neighborhood
plan
which which we haven't got here and we
have now got case history here in
mid-suffolk where there is a made
neighbourhood plan
we can resist inappropriate development
but we then go to the joint local plan
the joint local plan
has very little weight but it shows the
direction
that the mid-suffolk as has told the
government we're going to go
uh and this site has been put
well within that so if this site were
not
to be in that we would then need to find
some elsewhere to prop up the numbers
again we've promised a government
so but if we ignore the joint local plan
we're back with a with a core strategy
in a suite of documents
that would be deemed out of date by the
mppf and would tip a tilted balance
so you would just have to demonstrate
the harm
so if i now have to demonstrate the harm
this is the nub of it
my common sense tells me there is a
demonstration of harm
potential harm here but the evidence i
have
is absolutely zero from any of the
console t's
so as much as i would want the
sensible thing to happen which is this
this have more than one access
the one the tiny crumb i've got from
here is
this site does not preclude the ability
to have another access on the next piece
of land next door
uh and and because that's there i
i have nothing for which i can push back
and refuse this application
but i think it's a sad state of affairs
that sustainable locations like this
have to rely on not precluding
to actually try and plan out their
planned future
so that's where i am chair thank you
thank you very much
uh council norris
thank you mr chairman uh i to
still have some reservations regarding
this application
um the impact of the cumulative
developments in the area on the local
infrastructure
on page 35 of the papers nhs england
state that there's only one branch
surgery within two kilometers
and this does not have sufficient
capacity
suffolk wildlife trust at the top of
pace 36
expressed concerns at the possible loss
of hedgerows and the general lack of
information
in the application on this point
and they state that a habitat
regulations assessment would be required
suffolk police have mentioned a number
of concerns on page 37 regarding
security aspects within the indicative
layout and i don't see
their recommendations reflected in the
conditions listed on pages 64 and 65.
i also still have concerns regarding the
indirect routes through the existing
residential routes
to the single access point for traffic
for this proposed development and the
possibility that access for emergency
vehicles could be impaired in the event
that there was an incident
at the moment i'm not inclined to
support this application
however i will listen to the rest of the
debate
thank you thank you councillor melon
uh yeah thank you mr chair um um
i think this my colleagues have
sort of covered a lot of what i was
going to say but i will just touch on a
couple of points
um clearly this this this key issue here
is the highways and the access
and we have highways as a statutory
council t saying that it wouldn't be a
problem
um i do find interesting from the papers
you know
we're told development would achieve
safe and suitable access to the site
but um the officer was unable to tell us
which route that would be achieved by
but because they have said it's okay you
know we understand
an appeal would be difficult to depend
to to
to defend but i really have a struggle
with this this whole idea that
a construction management plan could be
so finessed
uh could be so programmed that
deliveries would have little or no
disruption to existing road users i just
i just in in the reality of of
construction i
just can't see that happening the
officer held out the slight possibility
of a secondary access to the north of
the site if that
that northern uh sort of section of the
allocation
came forward um i mean
it seems to me this plan is not the only
possible way that this site could be
developed and i think it would be
possible to say
not this and and not to say never on
this site
but we're in a really difficult kind of
pinch point here where we don't have
the grounds easily to to refuse it but
i'll continue listening to the debate
thank you chad
thanks very much and council war boys
lovely thank you chair um yes i i find
my
uh my personal judgment on this story
when the uh
um i certainly think the impact
on the residents in the short term is
going to be quite awful
with hgv traffic and in the long term
there is going to be a further impact
because of traffic movements
could i ask you to turn your camera off
and see if that improves because you
keep cutting in and out and maybe that
will improve
proof
can you hear me better now yes thank you
ah
thank you um
yes um i think
um the case officer joe hopes as and
uh it's done
a great deal of work good presentation
and i think scott um
properties have moved as well they have
improved
the biodiversity um
a meter is not really a great deal but
it does have a significant effect it
would be nice if it was two meters
uh the number of houses being reduced
it's also
has been a reduction in the size of the
homes there are more bungalows so that
would actually perhaps reduce the the
number of um
vehicle movements in the future
this site has been allocated for future
development
this is in excess of that
proportionally
but it is seen as sustainable for
development in the future there is a bus
route
i according to the parish council the
buses have actually been reduced but
this is um this isn't fixed
is it it can be changed it could come
subject to demand there could be an
improvement in the the bus routes
it is close to the high school there is
um
pressure on the health centers and local
facilities um
i i i am feeling that it
being realistic it is it is possible to
approve
this development but i have got still
got very much concerns about
either road being the only access into
this cul-de-sac
development
thank you uh
episode he wants to come in thank you
chairman just if i may just just
thinking about this and
just picking up on on one point um
so uh we uh
have discussed the finally balanced way
this
this looks for members and i think i'm
i'm i'm reading that from debate
the construction management plan
presently sits as
a planning condition if members wish to
uh give it the teeth of the section 106
i'm sure that's possible i think that's
a mixed there's a mixed view about that
one
a breach of a condition is easily
resolved with a breach of condition
notice whereas a breach here section 106
a much more
onerous thing is a matter that one takes
to court so there are
there are choices in that about how one
achieves that um and one
one may still say well it's not really
uh
satisfactory um but uh it's
it's what we do i was thinking um about
the connectivity point that councilor
manslaughter raised earlier
um and i'm not sure joe if you've got
a photograph of the sector of it must be
the southeast corner of the public open
space that's proposed
and if you could just highlight that
area i mean
it seems to me that we have a condition
requiring
respect for the parameters plan that's i
think the third condition down on the
list of recommended conditions
it would seem to me possible to
include a condition which would
look for a connection to the public
rights away
to the public right of way there from
the public open space in some
uh in the submission of reserve matters
for that uh area
because i fully suspect that the the
mark one human being will probably try
and create
that anyway so i think it will be more
prudent to do it in a managed way and to
do that
at a point with lease effect so going
back to councilman mansell's
comment made much earlier in this
meeting
i think that's something that we uh
could additionally consider
councilman talked about the uh uh
suggestion of an additional informative
regarding the upgrading of
uh uh the footpath to a bridal way that
obviously
is a highways that matter not something
we can comment on here but i think an
informative to that effect
is is useful and creating these
connections will at least
make this uh will enhance the the sort
of the good design elements of a place
in its
ability to connect into the locality so
i don't know if those are useful
thoughts chairman
within the debate thank you i have no
other hands up so
um i'll just i i uh also
agree entirely with council stringer
stringer and mansell um we
are in a position where you've got 67
dwellings you've seen a reduced number
of
dwellings uh come forward uh we've seen
the bungalows and the affordables
which are what we what we wanted and
what we're pleased to see
we've seen the ecological or the ecology
buffers increased
and so we've asked them to go away and
come back
and make changes and and to be fair they
have relocated the single story they've
done lots of things that we have asked
and the question is about access to the
site and
that access to us or to me
feels wrong the problem is
that in i uh in a similar type scenario
accepting that there were two entrances
but there or thereabouts
i don't think we can turn this down on
the reasons of access
because we haven't as as cancer stronger
said we don't have the evidence
so this isn't ideal this isn't something
i'd be proud to support
this isn't something i think is ideal
but i cannot find any reasons
to turn around and vote against this um
that would
uh be acceptable if it went to appeal
and i think we'd lose
and i think it would be a so so that my
view is that i will be supporting this
is certainly not what i want to do it's
with a heavy heart it doesn't make me
feel
that it's the right decision but i can't
find any other reasons not
to refuse it um so that's that's where
i'm at at the moment so i will be
supporting this application
uh with a heavy heart uh cancer guthrie
yeah well um i i've heard i think you've
summed it up i think you've summed up
everybody's feelings
and um it is again with a heavy heart
that i will propose
the recommendation but with the addition
that if we can make an informative as
suggested
um by councillor mansell
which uh i hope uh will be acceptable to
her
so that's where i am thank you
hearing councillor muller thank you
chair having heard
the debate completely now and listen to
all the arguments for and against this
proposal
i am happy to second councillor
guthrie's proposal to recommend for
approval on this application
thank you chair thanks councilman
uh thank you chair uh seeing us as uh
as philip isabel uh picked up on a
couple of points that i raised i thought
i'd like to
thank him for that um yeah i agree i
think that people will
find a way through that that little bit
of hedging uh in that corner of the open
space so if we can formalize that and
make that a
a proper access point into the um
footpath for slade um and yes um i would
welcome
an informative i mean it is only about
half a kilometer that is still a
footpath
because the southern end of that path
i've looked on the os map
uh leads through to what i think is
church road or something
uh and and it is it becomes a byway so
you know it's half a kilometer it would
be wonderful if we could make that
accessible for bikes and horses
as well as pedestrians because that that
actually really will enhance the public
right-of-way
network so um given that those are going
in
um i think i will be supporting this
application this proposal
um that council guthrie has made thank
you
thanks councilman councillor matheson
and councillor stringer
yes i'm wondering how
um we don't seem to be losing appeals
these days and i i can't
i can't i have a heavier heart than than
the chair
i'm afraid i i really cannot cannot
support what i consider to be such poor
development
and the i just wonder whether if we were
to refuse this
whether the applicant would would choose
to choose between
choose between between talking to the
people
that own the land to the south or going
to appeal
and i think it's a risk worth taking
thank you
thank you council stringer
thank you chair uh
yeah i think we uh there there would be
another risk of course to
uh to uh uh
refusing this as well is that they come
back with the original scheme and take
that one to appeal
so their risks go both ways in all of
this
and i've seen enough risk uh go wrong
uh and go the wrong way uh for me to
come
i'm not comfortable about supporting
this in its character i'm not
comfortable
but i just don't have enough to stack up
what i would consider even
even a tissue of a refusal here what i
would
ask the proposer in fact i hadn't
realized it had been proposed
uh if the program secular to consider
putting the hgv uh the
the construction plan into that section
106 rather than rely
on a condition that may or may not be
complied with
and we could here rule out today that no
construction traffic should go through
the edinburgh garden route uh because i
think that
you know that we should do that as a
minimum
then if yes it all then comes in on the
shortest route
on the shortest way through this estate
and it doesn't take that labyrinth
that takes it all the way through all
those wiggly roads i think that's the
least we should do
and with that i would just be supporting
it but it would be a heavy heart
could i also put in a formative note on
that if we do approve this today this
council doesn't put a glowing press
release
well that sits with the chair of the
committee council stringer
but i hear what you say uh okay
so um so can we just come back on that
point that council
stringer raised please um
no i wouldn't um be prepared oh hang on
a minute i've got
builders out here i wouldn't be prepared
to add that because if you listen to sam
she said it was not up to her to decide
the route
and what she would do is listen to the
route that the applicant
offered and then consider whether it was
safe or not
so i wouldn't be prepared to add that on
then can i come back to you yes please
do yeah then
then i am forced into uh changing my
mind and
and i will be speaking against this
application now because it hasn't been
demonstrated me
to me in a plan that there's a safe
route uh and it's not going to be built
into that section 106
and i can demonstrate harm so therefore
i now have the evidence
because i don't have it in the section
106. i will be voting against this
planning application chair
okay thank you uh philippisbo wants to
come in
thank you chairman um there have been
various points i've mentioned through
the course of this debate and we've now
got a number of informatives and and
other points and i
as i recall council string had asked two
questions one of them whether the
construction management plan we're going
to section 106 and the second one is
about was about
where the construction traffic would go
into edinburgh gardens
now chairman we've obviously heard from
sam this morning
and i believe as i understood councillor
guthrie
she was not minded to include the
the the edinburgh gardens point within
the
uh the wording of this i may have this
wrong and please do correct me i'm
not sure i got to uh that is still an
option
and chairman uh you will recall earlier
in the in in debate i talked about
locking in the biodiversity net gain
elements within the section 106 rather
than presently sits
within uh the conditions and that's
possible if members so wish it and i'm
happy to take i think all of these
changes might
might need me to take them away for five
minutes to with joe just to put the
wording down to present back to members
for your
comfort that we're clear so what about
the construction point that's been made
in terms of the route so
is that doable or not doable
councillor guthrie because she's
proposed just so we have clarity about
what can and can't be put in
my suggestion is that if you leave this
as a condition
and you include that as a requirement
within the wording of that construction
management plan so this is the express
requirement
that there is no accident no
construction traffic shall we use
uh edinburgh gardens which i think is
what was talked about
then if that's not acceptable the
applicant can make an application to
vary that condition and you can consider
that on its merits so you you get a
second bite at that
very specific question and to my mind
that's
a perfectly acceptable way forward
you've heard what
sam had to say you know what you know
and you're minded to refuse
i think you you create a condition there
where you've set out an expectation
and if they want to make the case that
they must use edinburgh gardens then
that's
their case to make chairman so there's a
number of little points that washed out
here before you actually move to a
resolution i would like to do some
tiding
so that we are clear what is being voted
on but i'll leave it there now
can i come back um councillor hicks
um i'm i'm more comfortable with um mr
isbell's suggestion but i don't think we
should be
prescriptive um so he said leave a
condition with the wording in the
construction plan does that sound more
acceptable
um he was going away to work on it i'd
be happy with that but i don't think we
can dictate
what route it takes is my view on it
okay anyone else wish to come in
cancer stringer you want to come back
yeah can can i just say what i was
trying to achieve
was dictating which route it didn't take
because i was only offered three
possibilities
uh it puts me the interesting thing is
the the presentation we had also didn't
show us the full way out of edinburgh
gardens on the little video
uh i know that area it is chaos through
there
to take a small dpd delivery or post
office delivery van is bad enough
if you've got a 45-footer in there you
you would have gridlock
and it's that acknowledgement that if we
were to do that it would be fantasy
trying to get an hgb through there
so i say i i was trying to head it
you know the other way
so so so philip i think you've heard
the way how we want that worded to
encounter string encounter guthrie
so accommodate that place so so just so
i
i think i have that clear that we're not
dictating route but we're
we're saying that there should be no
construction access within that
condition no construction access
through uh edinburgh gardens i believe
is the point i'm hearing
uh as an amendment to the condition as
worded
and the other element of the proposal as
i understood it was that
there will be the informative that
counselor manslaughter raised regarding
uh upgrading of the adjacent footpath to
a bridal way as
a request to the county council um
chairman do you wish me to formalize
this with some wording so that um
mr carmichael will then put that in to
me it sounds quite clear i mean you just
covered the points
from where i sit i'm quite happy does
anyone else wish to come in
is the second are happy with that please
yes
yes i'm happy with that thank you
okay anything counselors string you
still have your hand up
nope so i do i just want you to just
just just
it's all about getting the information
to the members i've just brought up
clayton on a google thing so i could
look at
a map and navigate myself around this
area while we're while
philip's tidying up i would encourage
the members
if they if they want to look at access
put pull it up on
on a map and navigate your way using
other providers are available other than
google uh
have a little go on the map and and look
if you don't go
uh the shortest route out of there how
you would navigate
it is a complete labyrinth i just
encourage you to spend five minutes
before you make it
yeah i i mean i think yeah thank you for
that
um okay so philip do you need a couple
of minutes
or are you happy chairman i think
so in essence to put this as simply as
possible there's a there's a condition
recommended which is construction
management plan i would suggest an
amendment to that
which is uh to add to that wording in
which is a bullet about a third of the
way down the list of conditions
uh no construction traffic access
uh via edinburgh gardens
and leave that text there and the other
point was councillor mansell's
informative
requesting the upgrade of the adjacent
footpath to bridal way
uh as a matter of the county council
okay lovely thank you very much okay so
um we've got the recommendations on page
24 and 25
and 26 of our papers along with those
two additions that
we've just heard read out and i'm not
going to go to the key question chair
oh right sorry john yeah i missed that
yeah
what's your question yeah yeah i i just
wanted to clarify with mr
isabel uh what state the the applicant
has offered us
m42 and m43 um
on the building rigs um we have to
include that in the planning permission
but i'm not clear which stage
to make sure we don't need it at this
stage as as a condition please
so that thank you chairman i'm going to
take the liberty of uh
drawing in joe at this point in relation
to where we might
um uh add that yes yeah no uh thank you
catherine matson i think it would be at
this outline stage um and the applicant
certainly has indicated they're happy to
have that condition so
um perhaps we could add into the um
resolution as well the condition
yeah third one to ensure compliance with
those two parts of the building
regulations
okay thank you thanks very much okay so
on that basis with those three editions
and the recommendations on page 24 25
and 26
i'm going to ask the governance officer
to conduct an electronic vote
updated the recommendation in modern.gov
to read out as follows
so that application dc 180861
be approved as detailed in the officer
recommendation with the additional
conditions and informative notes as read
out by the chief planning officer are
you content with that chair
yes i am and is um mr isabel are you
content with that as well just to be
clear
uh yes so joe just from just for the
record the wording of the part m42
condition so the members have
comfort about around that that's
effectively a requirement
for the reserve matters to be in
compliance with that
can you just confirm that for me
yes yes so the um the applicant
identified that the
bungalows provided on the site would be
in compliance with part
m42 and m43 in terms of accessibility
um for with the um yeah in terms of
accessibility building regulations
um and so it would relate to the
bungalows on site just to make
members clear um on how the condition
would apply i'm just
quickly just checking one that if you
despair with me
um just to make sure that i have
answered that correctly um
and presumably chairman you'll want
provider and secondary to be comfortable
with that
sorry nearly there just want to make
sure i do give you the right advice as
to
um what the applicants have indicated
yes so
um it does relate to the single story
the uh 10 proposed bungalows that would
be delivered to building regulations
for two and then four three standards uh
at the reserve matters stage
okay so um council guthrie councillor
muller you're all happy that we proceed
to the vote yes i'm happy chair thank
you
okay robert over to you please thank you
chair
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov app
um you may need to log in again as we
have had over two hours of inactivity on
there
but if you complete if you haven't um
got the screen from if you could log in
once you get in if you please go to
today's agenda and then go to the plus
sign in the top right hand corner
from there you'll get a subsection on
attendance and voting please click on
that and that will take you to
the voting tab for today's meeting from
there if you could please
choose the light blue line which
indicates the vote is in progress
just waiting on two more chairs
everyone okay voting anyone struggling
cancer war boys
hello i'm waiting very slowly for this
to reload i've been i've crashed out
i'll have to vote
um anyone else should we take a
verbal call on that sure we're just
waiting for councillor
oh it's just council of war boys
so if i could take your vote verbally
council ball boys if that's okay
yeah uh for approval
reluctantly thank you councillor so
with the council of war boys vote that
makes it nine votes four
and three against so the motion is
carried
okay thanks members that was uh
i think a particularly difficult one um
okay so
we have no site inspections to report no
other business so thank you for your
time this morning
enjoy the weekend when it comes and
close the meeting it's 11
57. thank you everyone and thank you
thank you
you